merci d'être avec N direct c'est touche
pas mon poste merci d'être là les chéris
et tiens viment tu disais un truc
intéressant il y a un instant parce que
les gens réagissent énormément sur le
débat qu'on a on va faire le point
people dans un instant mais les gens
réagissent énormément tu disis un truc
en fait et tu dis un truc vrai si tuas
si c'est intéressant mais je pense queH
intéressant c'est plus intéressant pass
audhi parfois le système il est fait
d'une certaine manière que d'être au
chômage tu gagnes plus d'argent que si
tu vas travailler le chômage rapporte
plus que que le travail alors pas dans
tous les cas alors les gens vont dire
oui mais c'est pas un jeu d'être au
chômage je comprends bien je parle pas
de celui qui a eu une situation il s'est
fait licencier une entreprise qui ferme
où il a quitté un CDI par des choix je
parle pas du chômage de 2 3 ans je parle
du chômage de longue durée moi j'ai des
personnes que j'ai en tête qui sont ils
iront jamais travailler parce que le
système est fait d'une telle manière
qu'ils ont peut-être aussi des enfants
donc s'ils prennent les aides s'ils
prennent leur chômage ou les tout toutes
les aides qu'il peuvent avoir et rest
accumuler peu importe tout ce qu'ils
peuvent avoir ils vont faire 1002 1003
et au travail on va leur dire bah toi on
te connaî pas tu as pas de diplôme ni
d'Adam ni d'è vient premier jour 1003
1004 net il va dire je vais pas aller
travailler pour gagner 200 € de plus
Jeur chez moi je chez moi mais il y a
des gars il y a des gars qui cherchent
vraiment du
travail il y en a énormément regard ce
qu' m'a dit à la pub non mais c'est pas
possible mais qu il dit tout ce qui sort
de sa bouche c'est des conneries il a
dit a 1450 profiteurs en France mais tu
en as pas marre mais tais-toi tais-toi
tais-toi on en peut plus mais c'est pas
possible 1450 profiteurs mais c'est tous
ceux qui la BAR mon fils non mais
qu'est-ce qu'il raconte mais mais
comment tu peux dire une connerie pareil
ça se ça ça se calcule en milliards les
profiteurs je
te je te parle en
argent milliards tu veux que je te dise
la vérité ce qu'il faut faire les deux
trucs à faire il faut s'attaquer aux
deux fr la fraude fiscale et tout ce qui
est voilà tu vois pe être intraitable
avec l'évasion F exct voilà non mais
tout ce qui est fraude ça déjà tu vas
voir tout ce qui est fraud déjà tu vas
voir tu et de il faut s'attaquer à tous
les profiteurs la fraude sociale
exactement tu vois tu vois tu sais
mettre
des
trillire on lui donne 1000 € dans sa
poche il dit merci la FR je prends je
pas travaer croyez sérieusement qu'il a
des gens qui vont rester 15 ans sans
boulot toute mais là qu' est
déconnecté c'est là qu'il est déconnecté
parce qu' Gal Gal galère pas les gens il
y a des gens au chômage vraiment qui
galèrent qui doivent se réiner qui
doivent revenir dans le monde du travail
qui qui vivent l'enfer à cause de leur
formation leur diplôme et cetera ils
sont plein de motivation on leur ferme
les portes pour des discriminations peu
importe des compétences l'âge peu
importe ceux-là on les laisse à part
parce qu' ils en veulent je te parle de
ceux de longue durée me dis pas qu'il
galère dis pas qu'un mec qui prend 1000
balles par mois et si on lui dit tu vas
aller faire ce boulot là pour 1
je vais balancer des abonnements dans le
Pass Navigo va falloir que je mange le
midi va falloir que je me trouve des je
vais payer des impôts derrière je reste
chez moi à 1000 balles ça
tombe il font des petits boulot à côté
ça
existe existe moi je donne mon avis me
cri pas dessus je suis un peu d'accord
avec lui mais mais qu'estce que tu
veux alors déjà je trouve que rad il a
aucune humanité voilàas aucune humanité
et ok donc je suis totalement d'accord
la France pas t les mais donné la France
c'est pas des c'est pas des Gogol genre
ils ont fait rentrer des gens ils sont
là maintenant on peut pas les laisser
crever c'est pas des animaux et même
encore les animaux on on les vise pas là
on les soig donc à un moment donné non
je suis désolé il y a des mamans il y a
des bébés c'est c'est c'est quoi ça
d'humanité on est on est singalis on est
congolais on est des humains avant je
comprends quand vous parlez je comprends
quand vous parlez et j'accepte plus j'en
peux plus de Verdez il connais rien à la
vie aux gens des profiteurs il y a que
ça qu'est-ce qui répond à ça au
profiteurs Gil ver sache-le sache-le la
France aujourd'hui pas que000 la France
aujourd'hui je te le dis aussi victime
et je te dis que c'est bien plus grave
que ce que tu ne crois des profiteurs et
de ceux qui profitent de la France et du
système sachele alors qu'il y a des gens
qui travaillent énormément et qui
comment tu peux avoir un agriculteur qui
travaille qui prend moins qu'un gars qui
travaille pas mais mais on est où en
fait on est où là mais je te parle des
agriculteurs c'est un exemple il a
raison il y en a plein d'autres non mais
mais mais tu dis quoi toi tu dis quoi tu
dis quoi regardez pas comme ça mais je
dis que les gens sont r il n pas choisi
les long il pas choisi
arrêies y a qui chois il a une
différenceêè y en a qui l'ont choisi
parce qu'il y en a qui veulent pas
travailler d'abord au chage si tu as
travailléouver pour entre le momentar au
il s'en est passé du temps souvent il se
passe un an et demi 18 mois dans la
plart dans la plupart des cas donc les
mecs s'ils sont r depuis plusieurs
années c'est qu'ils l'ont voulu so avec
le peuple regarde ce que dis g bravo il
y a des gens qui vont pas bosser car
plus chez eux et plus que les métiers
passion bravo connectez-vous g ver qui
dit
n'importes bien de travailler quand on a
le RSA la mesure
de
tu c'est pas nouveau c'est déjà en
vigueur en
2025 on va Rapp GAB je trouve aussi
c'est très bien encore le je pas dire
guignol je
dire au nez ça br
que que des guignoleries mais pourquoi
tu es contre en fait parce que texqu
parce que Gil verdz tu n'as pas compris
pourquoi il est contre parce que Gilles
Verdez est pour la France de l'assistana
la Gill Verdez il est pour la France de
laassistana et Gilles Verdez il est pour
la France de l'échec c'est-à-dire que
dès qu'il y a quelqu'un qui est en échec
ou qui est en situation de délinquence
il va aller l'aider dès qu'il y a
quelqu'un qui est en situation de
travailler et qui mine de rien a des
difficultés il va comm il est pour les
squaturs les Cambri ah si
de voil écoute-mo bien lepar de la
télévision monde champion du monde de la
connerie
to alors Gabriel a confirmé qu'il faudra
travailler minimum 15 he par semaine
pour obtenir le RSA et que la mesure
sera généraliséici la fin deannée bravo
gabripè je P qu' pr d'Ar
mesir compris d'ailleurs pour les gens
effectivement qui sont honnêtes dont
parler don par R
TR le permet de revenir untit peu dans
ce monde
travail les Ch j'aimerais qu'on entende
juste parce qu'on on va le faire ça
demain on vaarler demain j'aimerais
juste quand même qu'on entende pourquoi
Gilles Verdez le génie de l'échec est
d'accord n'est pas d'accord avec cette
mesure de gabrielal écoutez prenez des
notes et vous allez voir la nu c'est
contre aussi la contre amis sont contre
c'est normal ses amis sont contes donc
il est contre voilà non mais ses amis
auraient dit on est contre on est contre
N
a il aura oui s'ppelle le RSA sous
condition on est d'accord je ne veux pas
de condition RSA RSA ce sont des gens
qui vont toucher 607 € 91 pour un coup s
enfants qui n'ont rien qui sont à la rue
qui sont incapables de pou une activités
compquisse-moir laissez-mo finir d'autre
part d'autre part il y a 2 millions de
personnes qui sont concerné d'accord
pour que la mesure s'ppque il faudra
être inscrit à France travail ancien pô
emploi aujourd'hui il y a que 40 % de
ces gens qui le sont 60 % des gens
doivent s'inscrire à France travail vous
pensez qu'ils vont aller au guichet de
France travail et s'inscrire et où sont
les employés les les France travail bah
arrêtez France travail va être submergé
c'est de l'utopie totale on peut
annoncer des trucs merveilleux mais ça
ne se fera jamais c'est impossible
justement ça participe d'un retour à
l'emploi ça justement ces gens-là qui
sont hors du système et qui sont
peut-être extrêmement malheureux d'être
hors du système on les remet dans ce
système en en les mettant en leur
demandant de se connecter justement ou
d'aller sur France travail de de
retourner au à Paul emploi enfin qu'on
naappelle plus Paul emploi maintenant et
de et de remettre un pied dans ce
mondelà qui leur est justement euh
étranger et donc finer le moment c'est
c'est formidable arrêtees je t'ai pas
donné la parole ça s'est fait dans 19
départements tous les départements de
France g se sont battus pour avoir cette
mesure chez eux parce tellement ça
marche et tellement c'est positif et
tellement ça va dans le bon sens tu VO
mais mais qu'est-ce qu'il a fait lui il
a fait quoi ils ont fait quoi ses amis
merit
merich suis en TR de vérifier parce que
je suis sû tu une grosse connerie je
crois pas obligé d'être inscrit àemplo
pour toucher
lea cette nouvelle mesure là il
faudra il a dit deux fois n'importe quoi
déjà tu es pas obligé d'être inscrit
àemplo pour le toucher en plus tu parles
des
gens les gens à la rue on une
problématique ils ont pas d'adresse eu
malheureusement n'arrivent pas à faire
de démarche mais RA c'est un CDD de sur
pas CDI RA le RSA c'est fait pour AER
pour aider les gens à traverser une pass
cette mesureette mesure c'est pour faire
de la réinertion parce que c'est le
cancer de la France on en a Mar voilà
bravo c'est la loi et c'est impossible à
mettre en place avec ça on va aller dans
le mur
direct pas d'erreur il faudra êre
insrit rien tu dis que des conneries
mais non
mais faudra faudra
êtrei tais-toi arrête de crier pour rien
problè de s'incr auemp je me suis
inscrè s arrê sur le truc qu qu' Ron P
fr absorber million et quel de
gens fa tout ça c'est fait pour que
plein de gens n' plus le tu sais
pourquoi c'est fait aussi pour la
réinertion parce que pour les me a boss
mais to comm pour la France
de voilà je dis et la France
qui des gens qui profitent du système
voilà pourquoi et voilà g tu es pour ça
et tu bizarrement comme tes amis de la
nu sont contre tu es contre comme
d'habitude et ce sont tes amis bizar tu
as
tour
[Musique]
amis amis amis amis de la même manière
mesure qui est très bien j'ai pas dit ça
je te dis une autre mesure qui est trs
aussi que maintenant qu'on refusera de
CDI de suite sans raison valable on sera
plus on pour plusou chage ça c'est
bien Contin à toucher le CH pour ils
sont contre ses amis
C cont
M m regard g tout à l'heure tu as parlé
de 910 € c'est quoi
€ voilà 91 € pour un couple par
enfentendu ce qu' a dit l'agriculteur il
regarde regarde le SMIC le SMIC ou pour
le coup pour les deux mais le SMIC pour
une personne c'est 15300 déjà pour le
couple il que 400 balles d'écart après
si le couple ils ont des enfants
derrière ils vont toucher d'autres Z tu
es d'accord avec moi ils ont deux
enfants c'est 12 ça monte déjà là c'est
plus la peine d'aller travailler rideau
parce que si tu mets le transport si tu
mets la bouffe si tu mets l'impôt sur le
revenu si tu mets la garde des enfant si
tu mets tout réuni ça ça sert plus à
rien d'Er
travailler fa ch quelqu quelqu'un qui
est en condition pour aller travailler
il doit pas pouvoir refuser un boulot
qui est qui est qui un petit boulot à
1003 1350 net il doit pas pouvoir le
refuser il doit pas pouvoir dire je suis
à 1002 maisah alors je vais refuser le
boulot ça va me faire gagner 150 € de
plus ça sert à rien j'ai les transports
j'ai la bouffe j'ai les impôts sur
revenu c'est pour ça que il reste en
moyenne 7 ans c'est pour ça qu'il faut
il faut se dire à un moment donné à un
moment donné pour aller chercher de
l'argent comme tu as dit à un moment
donné il faut peut-être dire la fête est
finie on a plus les moyens au lieu de
taper sur les étrangers qui sont malades
on va peut-être taper aussi sur tout le
monde on va peut-être aussi voir les
gens qui veulent pas jouer le jeu celui
qui veut pas jouer le jeu qui veut pas
dire à la France regarde moi je vais
travailler je vais payer des impôts
comme un autre celui-là on va lui dire
la fête est bientôt finie Fall tu
trouves Franceen France qu' bénéficie
d'ê comme ça aucun pays au monde il des
AES comme ça c'est impossible notre
honneur mais non mais notre honneur
c'est notre chute c'est pas notre hneur
est généreux avec l'argent qu'on a
pas il est généreux avec des conneries
il des conneriesm à 18h50 il finit à
21h15 c'est pas compliqué oui qu'est-ce
non on pourrait faire comme G on
pourrait dire oui il faut aider les les
les les étrangers c'est beaucoup plus
facile de faire ce qu'il fait lui que de
dire nous on va enlever on va enlever
des RSA on va enlever le chômage on va
enlever ceci on va enlever cela ça c'est
ça c'est pour se faire démonter pour se
faire taper dessus il y a rien de mieux
mais je pense que les gens qui vont se
lever le matin et qu'ils vont travailler
qu'à 6h ils attendent leur train qui
annulé ou je ne sais quoi ou qui cour
après des bus et que le 20 il se dit bah
là j'ai plus rien je suis à sec et
pourtant je travaille et on est le 20 et
j'ai plus rien et je vais faire un
découvert que je vais rembourser le mois
Prain c'est je suis dans l'engrenage de
mon découvert et la banque elle va me
mettre en plus des agios et le voisin je
le vois lui avec des Nik au pied des
survêtements il est en train de gratter
des rapidos toute la journée je peux pas
c'est tout merci est-ce qu'on a un
sondage les chées parce qu'on va passer
au point people et regardez le sondage
bon je suis sûr qu'il va être encore
voilà comme d'habitude voilà merci je
vir son corps à la ramasse tu es nul
arrête pas gagn un match que des
défaites sans déconner tuas 25 combats
25 défaite excuse-moi sen déconné arrête
la boxe merci dans ce point people on
parler